foreign
welcome back to the cosmic Wonder last
night we got the second official full
trailer for the Marvels Captain Marvel
Miss Marvel and Monica Rambo who is the
comic book character Photon all come
together in this film not exactly by
choice as it's explained in the teaser
trailer and this trailer they get
entangled as Monica Rambo explains it
basically every time they use their
powers they swap places with one another
but right away go ahead and let us know
what you thought about this full
official second trailer in the comments
down below are you excited about this
movie or not also don't forget about our
giveaway if you subscribe and leave a
comment to your automatically entered
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 so Marvel Legends items or some DC
items we pick one winner at the end of
each month and the winner gets to pick
one item now this trailer explains what
exactly is going on in Captain Marvel 2
essentially is what the Marvels is and I
actually think that there is a pretty
big Galactus connection here there have
been some rumors going on recently that
we might get a pretty big Cameo or
introduction and in the Marvels and
perhaps there could be mention of
Galactus in this film I'll explain the
connections in this video and how it
could link to Galactus there's also a
lot of really cool things to break down
that we see happening in this trailer
and we mentioned this in the teaser
trailer this official trailer also
starts off with the song Intergalactic
by the Beastie Boys which the first line
of the song is well now don't you tell
me to smile and this is actually really
really clever and it's kind of an inside
joke because when Captain Marvel the
first trailer came out everybody was
saying well Brie Larson Carol Danvers
Captain Marvel she's not smiling she
needs to smile more to be more likable
it was this big thing so now they're
kind of poking back at that with the
first lyrics being well now don't you
tell me to smile but of course also at
the same time the song is called
Intergalactic and this is very much an
Intergalactic film in fact some of the
first words of this trailer is Nick Fury
saying Carol Danvers prodigal child of
the Milky Way now the Milky Way is the
Galaxy that we all live in in real life
so of course that that's the Galaxy that
they are in as well basically calling
Carol Danvers the prodigal child of the
universe now if you're keeping up with
secret invasion you can see that Nick
Fury is back on saber he is no longer on
Earth so spoiler alert Nick Fury does
not die in secret Invasion or if he does
it's gonna be in some really weird twist
but I really doubt that it looks like
he's going to survive and go back to the
old Nick Fury that he once was before
the events of secret Invasion and before
the blip and secret invasion is going to
lead us into the Marvels most likely
with an ending scene or a post-credits
scene showing us possibly Captain Marvel
Monica Rambo Miss Marvel or maybe even
just Nick Fury going back up to saber
but Nick fear gets on the comms calls up
Captain Marvel asks her how it's going
and she says oh you know cold no air
space and this is interesting because
Captain Marvel can actually breathe in
space we saw this in Avengers end game
when she went and rescued Tony Stark she
didn't have a helmet on at all since she
was empowered by an infinity stone she
has a lot of awesome capabilities which
of course course we have seen throughout
the MCU now also during the scene you
can notice a few things like Goose
making coffee for himself we can see
Goose flip the switch now keep in mind
goose is a flirkin and not actually a
cat well kind of he's an alien cat but
he's a very intelligent creature you can
also see that Carol Danvers is kind of
keeping track of Monica Rambo we see a
picture of her and we see a picture of
her mother as well who of course was her
wingman and best friend on earth now if
you recall in one division it didn't
really seem like Monica really liked
Carol Danvers or Captain Marvel she kind
of blames her for not being there for
her mother because her mother did not
get blipped away and died during the
blip so when Monica came back after
being snapped she found out that her
mother Maria had died so there's
probably a little bit of animosity
between Monica Rambo and Carol Danvers
so the dynamic is going to be quite
interesting for this movie because
Monica is not going to really like Carol
Danvers that much and then we have Miss
Marvel who is a Captain Marvel Super Fan
and she's very young and she is a rookie
superhero at this point in time but then
we dive straight into what this movie is
really going to be about we meet Dar Ben
who fun fact is actually Tom
hiddleston's wife Tom Hiddleston of
course plays Loki in the MCU and now his
wife is in the MCU as Dar Ben and she is
the new Cree leader at this point in
time and she calls Captain Marvel the
annihilator and she says you took
everything from me and this seems to be
because of Captain Marvel defeating the
Supreme intelligence we found out an
Avengers endgame that Captain Marvel has
been going all throughout the Galaxy
basically helping people who needed to
be helped and stopping people who were
doing bad things so Captain Marvel of
course played a huge part in taking down
a large portion of the cree there is
also a rumor that darben could possibly
be the daughter of Ronan the Accuser
however this is not confirmed yet and is
looking kind of more like this isn't
going to be the case although the hammer
that she brings with her everywhere does
seemingly look a lot like the one that
Ronan the Accuser had but this could
simply just be a Cree slash accuser's
weapon in the Comics Dar Ben eventually
goes on to become the emperor of the
cree which it seems like that is her
role in this movie she goes on to find a
Bengal the twin Bengal to Kamala Khan's
Bengal if you recall from Miss Marvel
her ancestors did find the Bengal that
Kamala would eventually get on a blue
arm therefore making it a Cree and they
mentioned that it was supposed to be two
Bengals however they could not find the
other and it looks like darbin
eventually goes on to find that other
Bengal and she's using this Bengal to
open up portals and start stealing
resources from planets specifically as
she says she's going to return the favor
she goes to the planets that mean a lot
to our three main Heroes Captain Marvel
Monica Rambo and Miss Marvel and here's
where my Galactus Theory comes into play
if we look at this particular scene at
the 120 Mark in the trailer we can see a
portal open up from the sky purple like
the powers that she is using and we can
see her sucking the water out of the
ocean and from what we know she is
taking planets resources which sound
sounds an awful a lot like what Galactus
does consumes planets for their
resources for their energy now Galactus
simply devours everything with a planet
but you never really know what the MCU
is going to do and how they're going to
twist the comics now like I mentioned
there has been rumors that we could be
seeing some pretty cool cameos Galactus
could be one of them and if not maybe
mentioned or hinted at if not seen
himself and this could be our possible
hint the cree could have sought further
help for taking on Carol Danver since
they know that they couldn't really
defeat her Galactus could be someone
that they went to for help and darben
could almost be like a Herald of
Galactus Galactus could give her some
powers to open up these portals with the
help of the Bengal and start consuming
resources it's kind of a win-win
Galactus would get resources would get
energy and darbin would be able to
defeat Carol Danvers and take out her
revenge now I'm not saying that she is
an actual Herald of Galactus but
Galactus could simply be using her and
this could start to introduce Galactus
or a Devourer of worlds in Captain
Marvel they could simply hint that there
is a entity or a giant Galactic being
out there who feeds on energy and
perhaps they could hint that they were
using that being to try and Destroy
Captain Marvel try to destroy the worlds
that she loves now in this scene at 1 20
in the trailer this is actually the home
world of Prince Yan played by Park so
Joon and the reason that she is
attacking this planet is because Captain
Marvel is actually the princess to this
world she actually married Prince yon
because she participated in a ceremony
which she didn't really know what it was
what it was about but it was actually a
marriage ceremony where she got married
to Prince yon this is going to be one
plot point of this movie and she's
embarrassed about it and doesn't want to
return because she's embarrassed that
she got married not knowingly however
the positive spin to it is that she gets
along really well with Prince yon and is
kind of a diplomatic marriage at that
time so when she goes back her and
princion are actually really good with
each other and they actually show show
us a scene here in this trailer of her
and Prince yon dancing it looks like he
dips her it is very quickly shown
because they don't want to show you too
much but this might be the marriage
ceremony that Carol dembers didn't
really know about them to dancing either
after they were married or right before
and it's unclear on whether or not
they're going to stay married after the
events take place of the Marvels but
that seems to be why Dar Ben is
attacking this planet because that is
technically Captain Marvel's home since
she is married to The Prince and is
technically a princess of that planet
but we also do see that they go to Earth
because of course Monica Rambo and Miss
Marvel are from Earth but Carol Danvers
is actually from Earth as well before
the cree kind of abducted her after she
got her powers from the infinity stone
we can also see that the Statue of
Liberty is now repaired it's completely
repaired after the events of Spider-Man
no way home so this shows us that this
definitely takes place a little bit
after Spider-Man far from home if not a
lot after and the main plot of this
movie is going to be Monica Rambo Carol
Danvers and Kamala Khan trying to fight
darben and together in secrecy because
every time they use their powers they
switch places with each other something
that I'm assuming is probably going to
be extremely annoying for them at first
which we've seen in both trailers but
then they use to their advantage for
fighting you have to imagine that if
you're trying to fight three different
people and they are all switching places
using different powers against you at
all points that's pretty hard to fight
however for the three women it would be
pretty hard to master that as well but
ultimately that is what is going to
happen in this film the three of them
are going to come together as a family
and they're going to take on darben and
stop her from destroying many planets
throughout the Universe we also see that
Nick Fury has made up with Goose goose
did take Nick Fury's eye in the first
Captain Marvel movie however it looks
like they have made up and it also looks
like Goose has been up to a lot as he
has many many flirkin babies as we see
in this trailer which is essentially a
pretty strong little mini Army there
since we know what flirtkins can do and
we even see what they can do in this
trailer as well as goose helps out out
Miss Marvel devouring two people at the
same time so that's it for the Marvel's
trailer let us know what you thought
about the trailer in the comments down
below and let us know what you think
about our Galactus Theory could there be
a connection here could they hint at
Galactus in this movie what do you think
let us know all of your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and of course subscribe to
stay up to date on the latest news and
leave a comment so you can enter our
giveaway you can find us on patreon you
can check out our website and join our
Discord server and of course you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
well as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
me